[Music]
see water is a mixture of many things it
is a mixture of metal salts like
chlorides and sulfates of sodium
potassium calcium and magnesium and
gases like oxygen carbon dioxide and
nitrogen it's already a solution of so
many substances what else can be
dissolve in it
let's try take a bottle of sea water now
pour some juice in it the juice will mix
with the water then try this with
different liquids like milk
nail polish remover liquid soap it seems
as if it can dissolve almost everything
but now try dissolving oil in it we will
see that unlike the other liquids oil
will not mix with the water it just
forms a layer above the water this is
often seen when an oil spill occurs at
the sea it happens when the oil leaks
from the ships carrying oil from the oil
mines so why does oil not dissolve in
water why do some substances dissolve to
form a solution and some don't let's
find out in this video but before we
proceed let's first have a look at some
terms related to the components of a
solution we saw in the previous video
that the solution is a homogeneous
mixture of two or more components we
usually divide its components into two
groups the component in the largest
quantity is called as the solvent and
all the rest are called solutes so we
can say that the solutes dissolve in the
solvent to form a solution for example
in seawater water is the solvent and all
the metal salts and gases dissolved in
it are solutes remember a solution will
always have only one solvent but can
have more than one solute to dissolve
the net but in this one and the upcoming
videos we will only focus on binary
solutions with a liquid solvent that is
the solutions with only one solute
dissolved in a liquid solvent
so now let's get back to our question
let's say we want to form a solution of
these two substances this is our solvent
and this is our solute now we will have
a look at their molecules to understand
whether they will form a solution or not
we know that the molecules of a
substance attract each other so here
there will be attractive forces acting
between the solvent molecules and
similarly between the solute molecules
we denote the interaction between the
solute molecules as solute solute
interactions and similarly for the
solvent as solvent solvent interactions
now let's try to mix the two substances
we can see that here the solvent
molecules and the solute molecules will
get a chance to interact with each other
so in the mixture there will be three
kinds of interactions solvent solvent
solute solute and solvent solute
now the formation of the solution
depends on the nature of these three
kinds of interactions it has been
observed that a solution will form only
when these three kinds of interactions
are of the similar type and strength
what do we mean by it we will understand
this through some examples in the next
lesson we have seen earlier that there
exists different types of intermolecular
interactions depending on the nature of
the molecules of a substance to
understand them better you could watch
our videos based on intermolecular
interactions to stay updated and to keep
learning such interesting things go
ahead and subscribe to our Channel
[Music]